die gesundheitsämter wurden ja über
jahrzehnte kaputtgespart kann man sagen
und jetzt seid ihr auf einmal im fokus
man sieht euch man hört euch ihr wisst
schon nach der pandemie ist das alles
wieder vorbei
ja natürlich also dieser mechanismus
greift immer viele gewisse zeit wenn man
im mittelpunkt steht
entdeckt man die liebe die liebe kühlt
aber auch schnell wieder ab daher gut
aber sie haben sich ja schon bewusst
entschieden in einem amt zu arbeiten ja
da haben wir natürlich für schädliche
einfluss von politik uns auch bewusst
entschieden also ein bisschen
masochistisch veranlagt ist man schon
wenn man im jahr hat aber das ist
unbedingt nötig man muss natürlich mit
der verwaltungs freuden auch umgehen
können und die sind ja mitunter bizarr
ich helfe heute wo ich kann
und als man vom zdf bin ich mit
täglicher behördenarbeit bestens
vertraut ein café hätte ich für den
helden der pandemie attacke
das ist total aufmerksam von jetzigen
dankeschön und jetzt warten wir einfach
jetzt jetzt warten bis das telefon
klingelt hallo gesundheitsamt
reinickendorf was kann ich für sie tun
als sie müssten mal eben ihre nummer
geben und dann sehen wir sie nahe halben
stelle zurück sehr gut war was ganz
anderes wie stehen sie denn zur erhöhung
der rundfunkgebühren rundfunkgebühren
das machen wir jetzt mit es ihm
scheißegal
ok ja wie gesagt wir rufen in einer
halben stunde dann hat das mit der
vision gehört das fand ich lustig wobei
eigentlich bist du auf einem guten weg
weil das geht auch darum die leute auch
wenn es eine ernste situation ist ein
bisschen zum lachen zu bringen kann ich
irgendwie helfen unterstützungs und
immer mehr aufkam aufgaben aber wir
wohnen ja nicht mehr leute der kaktus in
unseren augen jemanden interessiert wir
haben diese der und ein betriebsausflug
ausfallen lassen wir haben letztes jahr
wir haben keine weihnachtsfeier macht
wir haben sonst auch mal zum geburtstag
gab es mein frühstück
haben wir es nicht mehr macht also
lohnen ob schon gerne mal wieder ist das
noch ein normales deutsches amt in dem
keine pausen keine feiern mehr genügend
nicht öffentlicher dienst ist kein
zuckerschlecken zu erzählt also ich
finde es immer besonders hübsch zu sehen
zwei tagen bevor sich die mps mit der
kanzlerin treffen dann hört man ja immer
ein geklapper aus münchen und dann guckt
ein bedeutungsschwangere herr söder in
die kamera und sagt uns ganz genau was
er glaubt für die nächsten tage dann
kommt die schlecht gelaunte frau
schwesig und möchte auch irgendwas sagen
diese mechanismen nerven uns so tierisch
weil sie uns vom eigentlichen arbeiten
abhalten also würde es vielleicht frau
schwesig und hänsel da auch mal gut tun
sich einfach mal hinter das telefonieren
zu klemmen einen tag lang im
gesundheitsamt mitzuarbeiten
naja das ding ist ja wir würden ja ganz
gerne hier leute haben die ihr handwerk
verstehen insofern bevor herr söder hier
sitzt am telefon hätten wir schon gerne
fachpersonal gesundheitsamt
reinickendorf hier haben sie sich auch
so was wetter geärgert habe ich eine
gute nachricht in den nächsten zwei
wochen spielt das für sie gar keine
rolle
gehören sie auch zu den leuten die sagen
zu hause ist es doch am schönsten
das war praktisch was würden sie machen
wir jetzt sparen jetzt hier reinkommen
würde ihn messen schokoladentafel
bringen würde
kein mensch kann im gesundheitsbereich
mehr schokolade sehen essen schmeckt sie
ja zum kotzen also so billig ist und
zweitens bringt alle patienten diese
mega tafeln als die schokolade als
letztes immer herbe sahne übrig bleibt
ja wir tragen keine schokolade ich keine
mehr schokolade habe ich verstanden aber
zum glück fällt unser dankeschön viel
üppiger aus
[Musik]
für euch
als wg von jens spahn treten werde
die leute ich wollte euch nur um ein
kleines auto bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
hallo hast du scheiße fährt haye